this is jenny you know what to do
jenny listen i'm sorry
okay i'm really sorry
i'm sorry i left you i went away and i
never came back and i just left you here
like
i really thought it would have been
worse to stay around
and well where i went was way [ __ ]
worse
you know how i get about everything
obsessive
about working out dating the wrong
people
drugs alcohol self-mutilation thought i
gave each one of those things
good hard dedication for years
honestly i don't know how i'm still
alive
i'm really sorry for telling you this in
a stupid voice recording
i really really wish i could see you
just one more time
just once but i can't
because mom is dead jenny
she's dead and i had to put her in a
place where nobody would find her
i don't even know how to explain it
she's awful
so don't try to find her because because
it's just really [ __ ] up okay
it's so [ __ ] up
but i'm gonna go i'm gonna go for good
i'm gonna leave and i'm not gonna come
back
i'm so sorry jenny i'm so sorry
[Music]